Dear Jesus, may I enter into the eternal divine order of God to place my absolute nothingness
in the heart of the Most Holy Trinity, to give to my God the joy of fulfilling the purpose of
my existence by doing all the acts of my life through the immaculate heart of my mother Mary
and in the divine will of God. And in this same manner may I live, pray, act, eat, walk,
sleep and do everything. May my soul be devoid of any other longings, wants or desires.
And may you my beloved divine will do with me whatever you want or desire.
All I ask is that you bind me to your most holy will so intimately that I may never swear from
carrying out what I know to be your good pleasure. And that I remain so docile to the movements of
your divine will that you never perceive even a breath of resistance in my soul to your requests
of me. Come divine will with all the angels and saints, especially my sweet mother Mary to touch
my forehead, to imprint on it the Holy Spirit and infuse in me true light so that I may understand
the truths and the good that are in these writings. Amen. We're starting tonight with March the second
1926 and this is a very important message for all our teachers who are teaching the divine will
because Jesus says we have to proclaim this message to be silent about us is to actually
entomb the message. So Louisa said I felt oppressed and with such reluctance to open my soul to manifest
what my blessed Jesus tells me that I would rather have remained silent forever. This is the feeling
level. It's not the will level and it's very important for us to distinguish between our feelings
and what our will our highest faculty is wanting to do. So she levented to Jesus and said to him
if you told me not to say anything to anyone ever again of what passes between you and me
from what an enormous weight you would actually free me. How happy I would be. Don't you see my
great repugnance and the effort I have to make. Now instead of just concentrating on Louisa
having a moment of struggle it's actually better for us to realize that what she's saying represents
a temptation that we have which is to keep it to ourselves not to proclaim it abroad and what we
actually need to do is proclaim it and this is why we are encouraging people to come more and more
and more into studying the divine will so that all of us can proclaim it wider and wider and wider
and it goes out like the waves of the sea out to all shores. So Jesus is now going to explain it to
her and give her the divine origin of the word of truth. This is terribly important if you're
studying scripture as well that you realize the divine origin of the word of truth and therefore
how sacred, how powerful, how creative it is. So while she was saying this Jesus moved in her
interior and said my daughter would you want to bury the light? Do you remember putting the light
under a bushel? That's in Matthew 5 I think it is or six one of those early chapters sorry it's
Matthew 5 14 15. Would you want to bury the light, the grace, the truth and so prepare the tomb of
your Jesus. Silence on anything which is truth, now notice we need to be silenced on lots of things
but not on the truth. Silence on anything which is truth forms the burial of truth while the proclamation
of the word, I've added the extra bit to make sense out of the text, forms the resurrection
of the truth. So that's why Jesus told the church to go out and make disciples of all nations
in other words the church exists to evangelize and to evangelize means to tell the good news to
everybody and we know from John 14 6 that Jesus said I am the way to the Father, I am the truth
and I am the life. So the truth is himself just as we learned back in volume 2 that he is grace,
he is life, he is everything. So the proclamation of the truth forms the resurrection of it. In other
words if we want this planet to resurrect from the desperate situation it's in now they need to
find out about the divine will because it makes light, grace and good rise again when we proclaim
the truth. More so since the word on the truth comes from the supreme fear this is absolutely
ultimately, ultimately exactly what God wants. This is his will and you read it in the Acts of
the Apostles and you read it in one Timothy that God wants everyone to be saved and come to the
knowledge of the truth. So it is his will absolutely. So the word had its divine field when in creation
with the word fiat I issued the whole of creation. Now that fiat is expressed in the book of Genesis
chapter 1 as "Vayomer Elohim" they have to use two words God said and this is what Jesus is saying
he decided to actually verbalize it to send the word forth and the word brought all things into
being. Now you go to John's gospel and the prologue and you go to Colossians chapter 1 it's absolutely
amazing what opens up if you really go into this. So in creation the divine fiat was issued and
brought forth the whole of creation. I could have created it remaining silent also of course if
God just simply wanted it he could have it but I wanted to use the word fiat so that the word
too might have divine origin. So the word of the gospel the word of all scripture has a divine
origin and since it would contain the creative power now if you study John's gospel I've done a
series of 46 programs on the first half of John's gospel for Shalom World TV and they're nearly
finished recently and looking for more but what you're looking at is the creative spirit-filled
life-giving word of God saying yes I will do it and so you know when he meets someone in his grave
like Lazarus he said yes I'll do it come forth that's the fiat saying come forth that's the word
going into the tomb of rotten death to bring out life. So there's an awful lot in this
so the fiat had to be expressed so that the word too might have divine origin and since it would
contain the creative power who ever must use it to manifest what belongs to me might have the power
to communicate these truths to whomever would have the fortune to listen to them. Now at this moment
I have the privilege of expressing this to you and therefore Jesus says that he would give the power
for that to actually go across so when each one of our teachers in our school is getting bigger
and bigger thanks be to God each one of our teachers has this grace and this power given to them
all you got to do is consciously click into it that's like if I want the light on I consciously switch
so let's read that again I think it's fantastic and since the word would contain the creative power
whoever would use it to manifest what belongs to me that's us teaching and proclaiming this
they might have the power to communicate these truths as distinct from reading the page
that would actually come through me to you and through all of our teachers to others
and it would communicate to whomever had the fortune to listen because we're giving the most
incredible good news to everybody for you then there's a stronger reason the you is now Louisa
for you Louisa there's a stronger reason in fact since the greater part of everything I tell you
are things which regard the supreme will it's not only the original word but the fiat itself
which entering the field again as in creation wants to make known the immense good
that the divine will contains so Louisa is not just getting information the fiat is actually
expressing itself again to bring forth the new era of the divine holiness the fiat went out to
bring about the creation originally and it's now going out for the recreation of humanity in the
divine will and it communicates so much power to everything I manifest about it this is the divine
will communicate so much power to everything I manifest about it to be enough to form the new
creation to Corinthians 5 17 the new creation of my will within souls so it has the power to actually
bring about this miracle in others I've been fascinated over the years that I have I've been
teaching this since 2011 I've been fascinated that sometimes a person gets it almost immediately
because they're completely ready and other people really struggle for for a number of years
before they get it but then they can go very deeply as fast as they want to okay and so
getting at Louisa slightly he says to her is this the love you have for me that with your
silence you want to form the tomb of my will so he's just alerting her to the seriousness of the
situation okay and so in the next wonderful paragraph we are going to see the three fiats
expressed in a prayer we all know since we were able to walk the glory be so Louisa said she remained
frightened and more afflicted than before I prayed Jesus to give me the grace to fulfill his most
holy will she said that is to do this writing and this proclamation and beloved Jesus as though
wanting to cheer me came out from within my interior which of course is Luke 17 21 again and squeezing
me tightly we would say giving me giving her a big hug holding her to his heart infused new
strengths into her now every single one of us are in the same position we can go back to him
get a divine hug and get whatever infused knowledge you need whatever understanding you need whatever
strength you need whatever courage you need god is not a respecter of persons the reason why
this is written is not to tell us that something wonderful happened to Louisa it's that it is available
to you it's for you if you want it so at that moment Louisa said the heavens opened and I heard
someone say in chorus sorry I heard everyone excuse me say in chorus glory be to the father
and to the son and to the Holy Spirit I don't know how she said but it was my turn to answer
as it was in the beginning is now and ever shall be world without end amen but who can say what was
happening she said in the word father one could see the creative power flowing everywhere preserving
everything and giving life to everything the mere breath of this word was enough to maintain
everything that he had created intact beautiful and new there's a transformation of the glory
be for you in the word son one could see all the works of the word renewed ordered and all
in the act of filling heaven and earth to give themselves for the good of creatures there's all
of redemption all creation all redemption in the word holy spirit one could see all things being
invested with the speaking operative and vivifying love I love the speaking bit if you underline the
word speaking because he's going to pick that word up and say it's our job to speak on behalf
of all of creation to praise God on behalf of all of creation to intercede for everybody it's our
job he gave us speech he didn't give it to the trees he didn't give it to the animals to speak
he gave it to us and he's going to demand that we actually do praise him in our rounds on behalf
of everybody okay so in looking at the sentence there about the holy spirit as well all things being
invested with the speaking operative that means a working situation and a vivifying love you see
we can say we we love God we may not be doing anything to let that love be operative in somebody
else's life and it's making it operative in somebody else's life that's terribly important and the
thing that comes to mind is the picture of the apostles they had struggled so much during the
passion and death of Jesus and they barely struggled back after the resurrection and here they are
gathered with our blessed mother and she trying to bring them into a deeper and deeper communion
with God and prayer for the nine days that we now call an ovina and then the holy spirit came
and he literally galvanized them into action and that the love there was no doubt that these men
loved Jesus there was no doubt about that at all no matter what their failures were they they loved
him and it's the same with the rest of us we actually love Jesus but you know get us to do
something is a different subject and so what the holy spirit did was he literally galvanized them
into action made them go out and there was Peter who was afraid to say anything to the Sanhedrin
when Jesus was on trial now preaching to the whole of Jerusalem not caring what was going to happen
to himself the holy spirit has that electrifying effect on the church and that's why for the new era
to actually be established we have to have the definitive Pentecost because the church is very
like the apostles before Pentecost yeah we believe and we pray and we love God and all
the rest of it but I mean we need to be galvanized into God's army that will conquer the earth
with love and joy and peace and patience and kindness and goodness not with the arms of the
other side so to me that's a very wonderful way of giving glory to God I mean we know the prayer
ever since we were able to walk but Louisa said who can say everything I felt my poor mind immersed
in the eternal beatitudes and my adorable Jesus wanting to call me back to myself she was an
absolute ecstasy about it he said my daughter do you know why it was your turn to say the second
part of the glory be because we all call it the glory be and since my will is in you it be fitted
you to bring the earth up to heaven the father son and spirit was bringing that blessed Trinity
down to earth and as it was in the beginning is now and never shall be is the proclamation of earth
to complete the loop of love I think it's fantastic so I want to give you some 86 verses 10 to 13
there so it was right for you to bring the earth up to heaven in order to give in the name of all
together with the celestial court the glory that shall never end world without end eternal things
which never end can be found only in my will and one who possesses the divine will is in communication
with heaven this soul takes part in everything they do in the celestial regions that's terribly
important and she is as though in act together with the celestial blessed we would say the saints
okay so there you have a wonderful insight given to the fact that our prayer even our ordinary
prayers are a dialogue between heaven and earth and we have our part to play to speak on behalf
of the earth so let's come to march the sixth 1926 and we have a lovely thing here that luisa was
called to be a copy of our blessed mother insofar as as it was possible and that was in a few volumes
back and now she comes to Jesus and says and which we don't know anything about her how can I copy her
this is an interesting thing and of course I've told you many many times that the Lord uses her
questions to give her more revelation that she needs so as I was in my usual state my beloved
Jesus came and holding my hand in his he drew me to himself up high between heaven and earth
almost fearing I clung to Jesus holding on tightly to his most holy hand I'm wanting to pour out
my pain with him which so much oppresses me I said to him my love and my life Jesus some time ago
you told me that you wanted to make of me a copy of my blessed mother yet almost nothing was known
about her of the many seas of grace with which in every instant she was inundated because she was in
the divine will from the first second of her being she said nothing to anybody she kept everything
within herself nor does the gospel say anything how could they if she said nothing it's known only
that she was your mother and that she gave you the eternal word to the world now actually what the
Lord is doing here is getting luisa to answer her own question but she doesn't see it and I have
noticed that in prayer I don't know a few that if you are meditating on something something that
you needed an answer to is coming into that dialogue between you and him and you get it at the end
oh that was it that was what I was looking for and this is what's happening to luisa here is
beautiful so it's known that she was your mother and that she gave you the eternal word to the world
but everything that passed between you and her the favors and the graces she kept all within herself
because the scriptures tell us you need to keep the king's secret with me then you want the
opposite you want me to manifest what you tell me you don't want the secret of what
passes between you and me I feel sorrow because of this where then is the copy you want to make
between me and the blessed mother so jesus clasping me tightly to his heart again we would say giving
her a big hug said to her my daughter courage do not fear nothing was known about my mother
except that which was absolutely necessary and sufficient to be known and that's what answers
the question that many many people have about the scriptures why didn't they tell us about
our blessed mother they only gave us the absolute bare bones and God only allowed what was absolutely
necessary to be known that I was her son and that through her I came to redeem the generations and
that she was the first one in whose soul I had my first field of divine actions everything else
the favors and the seas of graces that she received remained in the sanctuary of the divine secrets
in other words the king's secret was preserved however the most important the greatest the
holiness thing was indeed known that the son of god was her son this was the greatest honor for her
which raised her above all other creatures therefore since the greatest was known about my mother
the lesser was not necessary now the lord has told us that a number of times that if you are
called to the greatest thing the lesser is not important okay so the same will happen to you
it will be known only that my will had its first field of divine action in your soul
as well as everything that was necessary in order to make known what regards my will
in other words the revelations otherwise the rest of us couldn't go into the divine will
how the divine will wants to enter the field so that all of us may return to our origin
and how it anxiously awaits the soul to come into its arms so there may be no more division
between her and me that's the essential thing that louisa was first but that she's first to
open the door and the door is open for the rest of us to have the same experience
if this were not made known how could anybody long for this great good how could they dispose
themselves to receive a grace that was so great if my mother had not wanted to make known that
i was the eternal word and her son would redemption have produced you see the only person who could
give the apostles the information about the annunciation and the birth of jesus was marrying
herself so she told them the essential things a good which is not known no matter how great it is
has no way to communicate itself so if we hold the divine will as our secret and don't share it with
anybody else we have prevented the divine will from doing what it actually wants to do
which is to go to others and more and more and more and more until the earth is filled
with the divine will and the earth can stand up again and come back to god in the divine will and
therefore that the new Jerusalem can become a reality so only the essential things about louisa
will be known and you'll notice as we go through the volumes the attention is not on her at all
it's on the revelation that the lord is giving and uh we're watching the first human being
struggling to enter in and to understand it and to communicate it to others and as we're doing that
we're struggling to enter in learn how to understand it and learning how to communicate it to others
it's the same process and so jesus said and just as my mother was not opposed so my daughter should
not oppose what regards my will in other words to do it god's way and you remember as i have 55
verses four to eight my ways are not your ways my ways are is different from your ways as the heavens
are from the earth so jesus said look all the rest of the secrets the flights you do in my will the
goods you take and the most intimate things between you and me they will remain in the secrecy of the
holy of holies and he's ordered not to fear so in the same way when you and i are teaching others
and passing on this wonderful message to others you're passing on the message you're helping them
to struggle to get into it and understand it and put it into practice and so on but you're not
telling them everything that goes on between you and god because that's not the issue
that's not the point at all the point is to communicate what the lord is telling us to communicate
and it's the same with louis and it's the same with our blessed mother okay so let's come into
march the ninth 1926 and in this message the lord talks about taking an awful risk in creating human
beings and that uh his bed failed and he's he's taking taking an awful risk with louis to see
can his game succeed this time the language he uses is absolutely fantastic so louis has said
my poor mind was swimming in the endless sea of the divine volition my always lovable jesus made
me see the whole creation in act how if she sees the whole thing in one piece is beyond me but never
mind what order of what harmony how many different beauties so she's obviously seeing it like a
perfect picture each thing carried the seal of an uncreated love i think the uncreated and the love
should have capital letters that ran towards creatures in other words to give life and beauty
and grace and order and everything else to creatures and in descending into the depth of each heart
all things cried out in their mute language love love the one who loves you so much like that's
absolutely fantastic or as it literally is here love the one who so much loves you it's just the
other way around in other words what she sees in this vision is that the response to love is love
can't be anything else if if love gets a response that isn't love it's completely frustrated
i knew of a person at one stage who needed an enormous amount of help and required a few miracles
to get back on her feet she had been given everything material by her parents but her mother was ashamed
of her because she was the last of a long family of about 13 or 14 children and born to her mother
while her mother was in her 50s and the mother was ashamed of having pregnancy in her 50s and hid the
child away and didn't allow the child of any normal life but gave her all the material things she
wanted when i met her while she was still in her 20s she was suicidal i won't go into the story it's
it's a wonderful story of sort of recreation but just to say that love has to have a responsive love
and so louisa sees that the automatic response of creation to god who is love is love okay will you
come to human beings now i felt a sweet enchantment in seeing the whole of creation so i want to give
you sam 19 verses 1 to 5 there it's loving muteness was more than a powerful voice and it touched my
heart now the translation says wounded but we use the word wound differently so it touched my heart
to the point where i felt faint and my sweet Jesus sustaining me in his arms told me my daughter
all of creation says glory and adoration to our creator and love to creatures
that's love to us human beings why is that because they were created to serve us the angels were told
to serve us and creation was told to serve us and were the most spoiled brats in creation and does
does love come out of us does thanksgiving come out of us have you noticed in recent times how many
people don't say thank you and the identification of the human being in these writings is the ungrateful
one okay so here they are in their mute response to god saying glory and adoration to our creator
and love to the creatures that he has made so creation is a mute glory and adoration for us
because no freedom was conceded to it that means it wasn't given free will to give a different
response it wasn't given the freedom either to grow or to decrease it remains preserved in the same
way as it was created so we issued it from ourselves but we kept it within ourselves
and that is we kept it in our will in other words nothing in creation is allowed to go outside of
god's will it stays within god's will all the time and that's why you find in the book of
genesis that when man moved away from god's will that the animals moved away from man and
became in our opinion wild we were the ones who had gone wild so what do they do they sing
though mute the praises of our power beauty magnificence and glory i presume you know where
this is going that we have to be the voice expressing all of this in the name of all creation glory
and praise to you from the trees from the plants from the animals everything else we have to voice
this for them so we ourselves sing the praises of our own power glory and infinite love power
goodness harmony and beauty so there's mutual praise going on there creation gives us nothing
by itself although being an outpouring of all of our being it serves man as a mirror in order to
look at and to know his creator now you'll find the teaching on that in Romans chapter 1
verses 18 to 23 where Paul says that the the world in the first century was completely without
excuse because they could see god in all of creation they could recognize him and they should have
glorified him so when human beings look at creation we're looking at a mirror of god's beauty and order
and it gives him sublime lessons of order harmony sanctity and love so it's the first place you send
somebody who needs to find out about god go and have a look and ask yourself how did this come into
being one can say that the creator himself assuming the attitude of divine master gives as many lessons
for us for as many things as he created in other words you learn the first steps of wisdom by
looking at creation because creation teaches us about god if you go to the book of job chapter 38
verses 1 to 39 you'll get a wonderful reading on this where job has been in a discussion with his
three counselors who are pulling him as far away from god as they could pull and then the lord takes
him on a tour of creation and he says to him where were you when i created the morning
where were you when i said to the sea thus far and no further and so on it's beautiful absolutely
beautiful so now we come to the creation of man you've no trouble until you come to the creation of
man it was not so in creating man our love for him was so great as to surpass all the love we had
in creation so i want to give you a fusions one eleven we were chosen from the beginning that is
the very beginning of creation therefore we endowed him with intellect memory and will the
translation says reason so the intellect and the reason go together and placing our will within his
as though in a bank this is the risk you see we wanted him to multiply it to increase it a
hundredfold no for us who didn't need it but for his own god that he might not remain like all the
other things mute and fixed at that point at which we issued them can she hear the parable
of jesus about a man called his servants and to one he gave one talent and to another he gave
five and a decade ten told him to go out and work with them and the judgment came to the one who
refused to do anything with the gift that was given to him so we were to do something with god's
creation we were the only ones told we could actually take the materials and like a little god
actually do something with it and multiply it and make something for god or as mother trees of calcutta
says make something beautiful for god so placing our divine will inside of his will as though in a
bank we wanted him to multiply it to increase it a hundredfold not for us because we didn't need
it but for his own good that he might not remain like the other creatures mute and fixed at that
point at which we issued them but that he might grow ever more in glory in riches in love and in
the likeness of his creator roman's eight twenty nine i meant to say this to you before when i say
roman's eight twenty nine it depends on the translation i'm using in another translation
that could be eight twenty eight so you know if you if you look up these references just
realize that depending on your translation there can be a difference of a verse or two
the lord wanted us to actually grow like him and so that he might find all possible and imaginable
aids we gave him our will at his disposal that he might achieve with our very power the good
and the growth and the likeness of his creator that he wanted to acquire now some of them might
actually wanted they might be too lazy but never mind it's up to ourselves to take the gift that
god has given to us and to actually do something with it notice the operative love going back to
the message about the glory be so i want you to notice here in this sentence before we go on that
if we decide to take this gift that god has given to us he says you have my power at your disposal
to grow it so if we decide we want to share this with others we want to teach others we have his
divine will we have his power we have his grace we have all the gifts all you've got to do is open
up receive that's all and trust him and move and do it okay so let's come to the next paragraph then
so with this wonderful gift that's given to us we become like a little god in creating man
our love wanted to play a risky game by placing our things within the little circle of the human will
a stone a bank in other words you know to see what the bank actually work they hadn't tried this with
anything else in creation so our beauty our wisdom our sanctity our love and all the other divine
attributes were put in this bank and our will was to become the guide and the actor of his operating
or his working not only to make him grow in our likeness but to give him the shape of a little god
so i want to give you sam 82 verse 6 i said you are gods all of you sons of the most high jesus
quoted that in john 10 34 and you have sam 8 verses 5 to 8 yet you made us little less than a god and
you crowned him with glory and honor and so on therefore he said now we made him a little god
that's why you're told in genesis that the man was told to rule the earth he was not a servant
he was the lord he was the ruler small l l ord therefore our sorrow was great in seeing that
these goods were rejected in the fall and for the time being look at the way whole millennia can be
passed over in a few words for the time being our risky game failed but even though it failed
it was a divine game which would have to have its final solution a divine game can't fail
therefore after many years i were talking about millennia okay my love wanted to gamble again
and it did so in my immaculate mother and in her the game did not fail so success number one
is the blessed mother and in the next paragraph success number two has to be luisa and then
for the rest of the entire message the rest of the success has to be the rest of us
so what does success mean success meant that our blessed mother surrendered her will
from the very first instant of her being so our game did not fail it obtained its full effect
and therefore we gave her everything because the the rule is i give him everything he gives me
everything so we entrusted everything to her god could trust her because her will was completely
given to him he can't trust us if our will is not completely given it's actually that simple so
what is the risk that he's talking about the risk is that god knew that satan who had already created
havoc in the heavens had come down to the earth with his minions would go and attack this creature
who was so highly gifted by god i sure he even had the temerity to approach jesus himself
you see it in the wilderness and so the risk was that satan might succeed in seducing
the human race into rebellion as he had succeeded with one third of the angels
so god knew the risk he was taking and how big it was so that that was the the risk so
fast-forward several millennia now you must know that our love wants to play the risky game with
you that's louisa also so he's going to get success number two so that you united with
the blessed mother and this is why she was told she had to be like our blessed mother like her
doesn't mean becoming mother of the incarnate word it means that you give your entire will to god
that's being like her and so you would be united with the blessed mother
and you may let us win the game by allowing us to make up for the failure with the first man
adam the failure that he caused us and so our will restored in its victories might place its goods
in the field once again which with so much love it wants to give to creatures now so the lord says
we're starting again we're trying again and this time you're the chosen creature
adam was the first blessed mother was the second louisa is the third and so he's telling louisa
really that the whole future of humanity rests on her shoulders most of him shocking to hear it
and just as through the holy virgin that i recovered from my gamble the translation of that
sentence is horrendous he just said i i succeeded through our blessed mother so she made the son of
redemption rise in order to save lost humanity so in the same way through you louisa i will make the
sun of my will rise again that it may follow its course in the midst of creatures in other words
that the era of the divine holiness can take place this is the reason for so many graces of
mind which i pour upon you and for the great knowledge about my will if louisa was just to be
an ordinary saint and reach the fullness of union with god the lord wouldn't have to give her all
this grace and all this experience and all this revelation it was because she was given the mission
to open the door to the new era of the divine will that all of this was necessary it's nothing
else but my risky game which i am forming in you and therefore he said be attentive that you may not
cause me watch this the greatest sorrow i could receive in the whole history of the world i would
have dropped dead at the moment if louisa fails him he said it would be the greatest sorrow he had
ever received from anyone what a burden it would be the failure of my second game i know he said
you won't do this she'll be terrified when he's finished my love will be victorious and my will
will have its fulfillment so now you know why a few messages back louisa was told that the weight of
the world was on her shoulders the future depends on her yes just as the future depended on our blessed
mothers fiat as well jesus disappeared and she said i remained concerned she usually says she's
terrified i remained concerned about what he had just told me the wall abandoned to his divine will
what he has just said would make her cling to the divine will dear life because the the risk is so
terrible jesus alone knows the torment of my soul about everything i am writing and my great
repugnance and putting these things on paper which i would rather have buried i felt like fighting
against obedience itself but the fear of jesus won and so i continue to write but i don't want to write
not my will but die and be done then my sweet jesus came back and seeing me concerned he told me my
daughter why do you fear do you not want me to play with you now sometimes she doesn't appreciate the
games you will put in nothing of your own but the little flame of your will which i myself gave you
in creating you so he says to her i'm doing everything in you and through you the only bit
you really have to give is the gift of your will and if you give the gift of your will everything
else follows i think we need to take that on board as well that the thing he's looking for is
the gift of our will in all its fullness moment by moment he wants it and given at a greater and
greater depth because he will do everything else so that's what all he's looking for and so
all the risk of my goods will be mine you see if if the will is handed over to him the divine will
takes over and therefore the risk goes out of it do you know how to copy my mother therefore
come with me before the divine throne and there you will find the little flame of the will i love
this it is absolutely gorgeous come to the throne he says and there you'll see the little flame of
the will of the queen of heaven now why is it called a little flame she's the greatest saint but when
you compare a human being with the divinity there is no comparison therefore it is little and you'll
find it at the feet of the supreme majesty which she placed into the divine game in fact in order
to play one must always put something of one's own this is terribly important and this is this
significance of the little drop of water that is put in at the offer tree to represent us in the
chalice that tiny drop of water represents our gift of ourselves our participation in the whole
mystery of redemption and he says no you've got to put in something yourself so if we don't make this
gift we're not part of the game one must always put in something of one's own otherwise the one who
wins has nothing to take and the one who loses has nothing to leave and since i won in the game
with my mother she lost the little flame of her will but happy loss by having lost her little flame
leaving it as continuous homage at the feet of her redeemer what a wonderful way to make
reparation for the whole of humanity i leave my will in the divine will at the foot of your throne
to make reparation for the rebellious wills of humanity so that you bring them around
so there she left it with continuous homage at the feet of her creator she formed her life
in the great divine fire which is god growing within the sea of the divine goods and therefore
she could obtain the longed for redeemer because she entered into the divine she was operating
entirely on the level of above not on the level of below so in the next paragraph then we face
the fact that louises will sacrifice to god gives god the freedom to bring about their third fiat
and our wills sacrificed to god gives him the freedom to actually raise the human race to the
new level so as things are getting worse and worse and they will get worse we have something very
big that we can do to help the whole of humanity now it's your turn louise and he's saying it to us
as well to place the little flame of your little will near that of our inseparable mother so think
of a little bundle of tiny flames little candles burning at the foot of the throne of god and our
blessed mother in the center and all the rest of us the little candles all around her burning at the
same time all our wills before his will so put your little flame near that of our inseparable mother
so that you too may be formed in the divine fire and you too may grow with the reflections of your
creator to Corinthians 3 18 you become that which you worship you become like that which you worship
and there you will find grace before the supreme majesty to be able to obtain the longed for fear
there you will find grace there you will find favor before the lord sacrificed offered given
at the feet of the lord completely surrendered he's not looking for big feet of valor from us
at all this is what he's looking for and in the next tiny paragraph louise obeys in one instant
she said i found myself before that inaccessible light one Corinthian 6 16 and my will in the shape
of a little flame placed itself near that of our celestial mother to do what it was doing but who
can say what i could see or understand or do once she's in that ecstatic divine sphere she can see
and hear and understand things at that level once she comes back to herself no no she only has the
human language i like the words and so i stop here so the next paragraph is really really wonderful
and so we finish with a very beautiful prayer tonight and my sweet Jesus added my daughter i
won the little flame of your will and so you have won mine now the first thing i want to say about
that is this is 18 volumes later we're on the 19th volume it doesn't happen overnight and yet we
offer ourselves offer ourselves continuously continuously continuously and finally finally finally there
comes the moment when it's done how will you know you will absolutely know because something is
fundamental is that cannot happen without you knowing and if you haven't got experience of it
having been done before now you're not there yet i have won the little flame of your will and you
have won mine had you not lost yours you would not have won mine now notice lost and found
now we are both happy and we are both victorious but look at the great difference that exists in my
will it's enough to do an act a prayer and i love you once and taking its place in the supreme
volition that same act prayer or i love you remains always in the act of being done without ever
ceasing but this is after the final gift of the will in fact when an act is done in my will that
act is no longer subject to interruption after it was done once it's done forever if it really is
done in the divine will because something divine doesn't stop and so it's as if it were being
continuously done the operating of the soul in my will comes to partake in the ways of the divine
operating so we begin to operate the way god operates this is sam uh eighty six fulfilled
you're like sons of god so the operating of the soul in my will comes to partake in the ways of
the divine operating when it operates it does always the same act with no need of repeating it
because it the same act is continuous what will your many i love use in my will always repeating
their refrain i love you i love you what'll happen to them they will be many wounds for me and will
prepare me to concede the greatest grace that my will be known loved and fulfilled now notice
he needs these i love use from us therefore in my will prayers works love all enter into the divine
order and one can say that it is i myself who prays works and loves and that's why it's so effective
and what could i deny to myself he said in what would i not delight so the final reference i want
to give you there is two peter one three to four that he gives us a participation in the divine
nature it's very wonderful stuff so thank you for joining us tonight and see you after our little
break. God bless.